and we're just gonna wait a couple more
minutes let our committee members get
settled thank you
okay good morning welcome to the special
committee on housing sorry for starting
a little late
um we are getting organized here as we
should have a pretty busy day of some
hopefully um good legislation coming out
of this committee so uh we're gonna get
started with the Pledge of Allegiance
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
um
so I want to thank everyone for being
here
um it's obvious that this mission is
very important
um St Anselm College just came out with
a great survey this month I just want to
highlight some things
um 78 of New Hampshire voters think that
their communities need more affordable
housing
58 of New Hampshire voters now want more
affordable homes in their neighborhood
sixty percent of New Hampshire thinks
that our towns and cities should change
land use regulations in order to allow
more housing to be built so this survey
um is kind of giving us our charge that
we need to get something done here so
hopefully some of these
bills and pieces of legislation today we
can file and really hopefully help move
the ball in the right direction so
um with that I have a a list to go and
and I'm going to we're going to get
started
so the first one I want to talk about I
want to call on representative Wallace
um this is regarding
building code and revisiting
um
an old amendment to a Senate bill so
representative Wallace thank you
chairman uh
thanks for everybody uh joining us the
end of the summer here
um
the intention with my amendment to
Senate Bill 78 which is now going to be
a standalone bill
was to address many of the concerns we
heard from virtually every developer and
Builder that uh testified before us in
that they have run into situations where
they get a project underway be it a
subdivision some type of development and
at that point in time when the project
was
given approval
certain conditions were in place certain
zoning ordinances certain fire
ordinances
Etc and then come time for final
approval uh certificates of occupancy
um
things have changed on the ground
uh according to you the local building
officials but not according to uh
statute or zoning ordinance so being
that we as a legislature cannot make
laws retrospectively we feel the same is
is true of municipalities uh counties so
what this bill would do is make sure
that only the um
zoning ordinances regulations uh and
conditions in effect at the time of
approval uh issuance of building permit
Etc would be
those would be the only conditions that
needed to be met for final sign off on
any of the projects so this is
preliminary at this point we've got to
make some we've had some input from uh a
variety of individuals Benjamin Frost in
particular he's got some good details
that we need to tighten up a bit but
that's what this bill will do
okay uh representative
um
thank you for that explanation I just am
looking at this language here and it
doesn't seem to be
the same way that you described it
seemed like you were talking about like
um when you're proposing a plan and that
it gets accepted by the board and then
before exception and approval something
changes then you uh are not required to
meet those additional changes
um but the language on
on 10 and line
18 seem to both be that the
um
the subdivision or plot was approved
and recorded at the registry of D's and
that only occurs like once it's actually
finalized and so so I think that that at
least this language is talking about
after it's recorded at the registry of
deeds additional changes not like when
it's it's getting proposed and saying
like at the at the Town level you know
the planning board accepts uh proposal
is complete and they've started their
clock as far as like
um
uh how long they have to decide and
stuff like that can you
um address that
um
that kind of time frame because it
doesn't seem to drive what what you were
explaining yes and actually that was
also pointed out by uh Ben Frost and in
particular on lines 11 to 12 and again
on 19 and 20. it refers to site plans
being recorded since they typically
aren't record unless there's some aspect
of the plan that affects the title I
we're going to strike and properly
recorded So that way that that would be
addressed
and I'll circulate this email to the to
the committee
okay so if I'm understanding you there's
going to be some changes to that
Amendment and we'll forward that to the
committee
so that we can evaluate that before we
sign off on it
yeah Damon
so just to clarify what you just said
represented Wallace if we're looking at
lines 1819 are you saying you would be
removing the words and properly recorded
in the registry of deeds yes is Ben are
you here today
would you like to speak to that since
you've uh you were so
um
kind of Point these uh issues out to me
good morning Ben Frost New Hampshire
housing
um thank you representative Wallace I
um the the email that uh representative
Wallace is referring to is one I sent to
him in which I had reviewed this and
pointed out to him that uh it's
um extremely rare in fact for site plans
approved by a planning board to be
recorded in the registry of deeds only
where they affect the property interest
by changing boundaries or clarifying
boundaries or having a recorded easement
would that be the case and in fact
um
pursuant to the the Platt law which is I
forget the citation RSA 478 something
478 1-8 1-8 there you go thank you uh a
register of deeds can properly refuse to
record a site plan unless it has
something within the plat law on the
plan and it is that sort of property
interest so subdivisions
always should be recorded site plans
rarely are recorded
if I can continue one thing I think
representative urkela was also asking
the question about what happens when a
an application is pending before the
board it's an accepted principle of law
that those are protected from changes so
while while an application is pending
before a planning board it is subject to
the rules that were in place at the time
the application was accepted by the
planning board or perhaps depending upon
how you look at it when the application
was filed with the planning board and
there is a there's a case
on that filing question that goes back
many years I forget the citation I'd be
happy to supply it to the committee if
you wish
there's also a statute that deals with
this sort of protection of pending
applications that is the design the
preliminary
concept well the design review phase of
planning Board review so before they
file an application if a call it a
pre-applicant the property owner or
developer files a design review pursuant
to the planning boards
adopted procedures then that is
protected from changes
for one year
starting at the time the planning board
declares design review to be complete so
it the design review might last three
four months and assume these iterative
meetings uh in consultation with the
planning board that are not binding but
if if the developers proposed something
under design review that is protected
for a year from changes to subdivision
regulations site plan regulations zoning
zoning ordinances
and during that time during that year
the applicant can then file a formal
application under the rules that were in
effect at the time design review started
so there is protection for pending
applications and even some
pre-applications
representative Walsh
thank you Mr chair and you might be able
to help me on this too memory wise I
didn't see it in here
um
does this mean that an approved plan for
subdivision would be approved Forever
Without
have allowing any changes so because we
run into this there's there's also
something in statute about a vested
property with a certain amount of
percentage of improvements done to the
infrastructure to get that best thing
that makes it forever
because a lot of things can happen I I
just let me throw an example if you get
an approved subdivision and it sits
there for three years in the meantime
the aot permits have changed this
permit's changed unless there's
significant Improvement to the property
they can still be required to make those
changes would this exempt that in other
words if this is the direction we want
to go by giving basically everything
here vesting
or do we have to look at the other
chapter and make some strikes did that
come out what is your um view on that
that's a great question Mr chairman
thank you representative Walsh in fact
that that very issue that you're
describing is this statute that would be
repealed and replaced okay uh and the
the issue that you're pointing out goes
back a number of years it was 2004 that
this statute was changed in response to
a New Hampshire Supreme Court decision
involving the city of Rochester where
there was question about whether a
portion of a development had vested and
the Supreme Court found that uh it it in
fact it had vested based on the level of
improvements this replaces that entire
statute okay
to help deal with that would you
recommend another area of the RSA to a
support this legislation
no I think this is the this is the right
place to put it is there is there
language to
address those concerns because I I see
those as concerns too I think it would
be unnecessary unnecessary okay yeah no
and I if I can I think I'm fine with the
two just wanted to make sure we were
okay and I don't remember all the
chapter numbers so thank you very much
okay so is there anybody else I'd like
to speak on this I know Bill's here I
just want to make sure would you like to
come up and go ahead
just introduce yourself for us please
good morning
um chairman Alexander and representative
Wallace uh thank you
to speak thank you is that better thank
you yes thank you for the opportunity to
speak my name is Bill McKinney I'm the
president of the New Hampshire building
officials Association and we have uh um
some sincerest interest in this uh
proposal here most of most of which
concerns unintended consequences from
this proposal
um as we look at this bill we start to
look at we don't understand if this is
retroactive to all existing Lots all
existing subdivisions dating back to
when I know I've dealt in subdivisions
that have were approved back in the
1970s and we're still building on
existing Lots from those now
due to that we believe that this bill
could actually cause for further delays
in permit issuances and delays in
construction
number one is access to outdated codes
many building departments don't have
code the code books that still that
would have been in existence back for a
subdivision Back in 1970 or 72. so some
of your larger municipalities may have
decent libraries but you smaller
communities they don't have the room
they don't have the ability to maintain
all the additions of the codes that
would be necessary
access to those codes is also quite
impossible at times the night the
1985 or 1985 Boca code is probably not
around the cable code is probably not
around anymore because they've been
replaced by the international codes the
state of New Hampshire adopted the
international codes in 2001. so any
subdivision prior to that could be very
difficult to even find a code that you
could you could reference
um familiar familiarity with outdated
codes
inspectors today are being trained to
the most current codes that are adopted
by the state of New Hampshire we are not
teaching what was what was taught in the
prior codes of cable and Boca anymore
they don't exist so as our classes are
now we're now teaching to the 2021 codes
as the state is under the 2018 but we're
looking to move forward
I think this bill will bring in
conflicts between the with the state
building and fire codes which states
were quite clear in state law that we
must provide provide for the provisions
of code that provide the greatest degree
of Life Safety
is failure of Prior codes to recognize
more current building materials and
processes leading to costly submittals
and delays if you look at the newer
codes and the materials and and
especially with engineered products now
that are that are being put into homes
that aren't natural products anymore
those those are now included in the code
if we don't have that code available to
us and we're now looking at a house that
was a subdivision that was proved in the
1960s or 70s you're now looking at that
person that developer would have to
submit all the engineering detail in all
of the engineering data and information
for us to to have in order to make an
educated decision that's time consuming
and it's costly to the Builder the codes
are starting to recognize this and
they're bringing these items into the
codes
there's there's more advanced systems
that are out there especially with HVAC
and plumbing and electrical systems that
make the homes more efficient less
costly for the homeowner
there's a failure of the older codes to
recognize proven life safety
requirements smoke alarms are carbon
monoxide detectors are some of the
biggest they didn't exist in the codes
in the 1970s they do exist in there and
now the next biggest one is lateral load
connection for for decks I'm sure if you
want to do some research you'll see the
statistics on Deck collapses injuries
and deaths that result each year from
properly connected decks to homes
um the prior codes also do not recognize
the evolution of lumber Lumber and
dimension reductions a two by four is no
longer a true two by four anymore it's
one and a half by one maybe one by
three and three three and three quarters
so
so because of that the codes as they
evolve recognize that the lumber is not
the strength that it used to be in the
codes address that we start to deal with
the impacts on rafter and joist spans
prior codes do not provide for the
current increase to ground snow loads if
and I'm sure all of you can remember
years ago we used to get very deep light
snow and it was it would blow around we
don't get that anymore whether that's
global warming or climate change the
snow that we're receiving is is much
more dense it has a lot more weight to
it due to that the newer codes are
recognized recognize that and have
increased the snow loadings for roof
structures
and last the process of adopting codes
is about 18 to 24 months that's after
the review from the building code review
board so you're truthfully looking at
relatively three years to adopt a more
current edition of the code where there
are public hearings held educational
processes happen and even after the code
is signed by the governor we have a
six-month delay period in there for
further education and bringing everybody
up to speed and what that six month does
is that if you have a development that
was approved during that time and your
permits were issued
those buildings stay under that code so
it's already in State Statute that
protects developments what it doesn't do
is it doesn't forever protect a
development that goes on for decades
maybe even several decades before homes
are being built and the codes are far
more advanced in the Life Safety aspects
I really believe that some work needs to
be done to this to address what the
primary concerns are of our legislators
and what I typically find that these
bills come out because there's been an
issue where somebody didn't interpret
code correctly and made someone do
something that they really didn't have
to and with that I would accept any
questions
thank you uh
the intent was not to address anything
that's been in the past and frankly I
had no idea that we still had uh
developments that are going on that were
approved in the 1970s that's not the
intent of this at all
um I expect it to be a bit more
contemporaneous than 1970 so that being
said would certainly have a provision in
there that uh you know this would be
modern codes going forward you know we
could even put a timeline be more than
happy to work with you on that say
um say for example we haven't approved
subdivision from the 1970s I think would
all be okay with saying okay well it's
got to meet modern building codes
because the construction is starting now
that's not what we're looking to do
um the intent of this bill was to make
it so that uh we didn't have let's call
it corruption going on or uh you know a
Shakedown of a developer a particularly
municipality might want something done
you know
kind of a quid pro quo you want to get
the approval on this well we want a
playground on the other side of town
one's got nothing to do with the other
that's the intent with this so we're
more than happy to work with you on that
bill
excellent if you'd like to provide
someone yeah some suggested language
we'll work it right in
I think yeah I think so I'm I'm going to
charge representative Wallace will work
with you and um Mr Frost and make sure
that we get this language down because
this is really an important bill that
hopefully can come out of this committee
um the idea is is once something's
approved we want to move forward with it
and hopefully
um all of these concerns are addressed
during the application process and not
after the process is over so that is the
intent of the build
thank you Bill thank you
representative
I guess I have a couple of thoughts that
if if the
if the
um building or the the plot was approved
and built
and it could still be existing from the
60s or the 50s or the 40s with those
existing
built to those standards
um
I don't understand why if that you would
have to do
something else other than what was
approved like we're like we're allowing
people to still live in those homes that
were built in the 70s like why couldn't
they
be living in the home built today
those
building materials are probably no
longer available you're not going to get
an actual two inch by four inch two by
four so
um and I don't think that any Builder is
going to be building
what we would call War homes uh in
current
in the current conditions I don't think
there'd be a market for them
I'll say
okay is there any anybody else to go
ahead bill
Bill McKinney president nhboa
again the building codes often and
they're directed now to start addressing
the issues of of what's more current
which is climate change global warming
whichever you want to go to and as you
can see the storms that we're starting
to see nationally and internationally
are much more intense so wind loading in
fact for is a key key issue wind loading
in the 1970s was far less than the wind
loading requirements that are in the
code now so does that cause an impact
and a cost to the to the developer
absolutely but does it make for a more
resilient Community I think that's more
important too snow loading is a key
issue snow loading ends up on roofs
because as I stated it earlier the snow
has changed the consistency of the snow
has changed but also we put far greater
insulation in the attics that doesn't
allow for the heat loss that used to
melt the snow off the roofs
so a house in the 1970s that was built
you'll probably see and you take some
time and look around you'll start to see
the sags in the roof right the SAG and
the Ridgeline because now you've
probably found that they've insulated
their home to much better insulation
factors than the 1970s but now that's
starting to impact their the structure
of their house the rafters that are
there aren't strong enough to carry that
snow load any longer so there are
several reasons why staying with an
outdated code that doesn't
recognize current environmental
conditions and see even is not really a
wise route to go I don't think
go ahead
um my
I I'm familiar with
um
some I guess
my my home was built in like the 50s and
if I replace something like I just
replaced my roof
and
I replaced it with the same
setup that was previously there
um
aren't we don't we normally allow from
for some type of like
um like replacing of existing conditions
on the ground no even if those
conditions on the ground aren't optimal
currently
yes building code and the existing
building code which is also adopted by
the state of New Hampshire allows for
existing conditions to remain with
certain certain conditions
um provided that that renovation or
alteration area doesn't exceed 50
percent of your your work area or 50
percent of the aggregate floor area of
the building which includes all Floors
Plus the basement in the state of New
Hampshire by an amended definition
um so yes if you are replacing your roof
it wouldn't re mean that you would have
to replace all of the rafters and the
whole structure you could actually go
and replace the roofing materials and
not have to restructure your home
so couldn't that same logic be applied
to
um
the the what the the language in this is
talking about as far as
um
let's say that that uh that the
regulations and the regulations and the
fire code and all of this shall be
um exempt as long as
let's say the the changes don't exceed
50 of the the structure
or or the you know the plan or whatever
the case that's a very good question and
that's already addressed in the building
codes and in the existing building code
so repairs maintenance of buildings
alterations Renovations provided you'd
only exceed the 50 the what it would say
is that if you're doing alterations to
that area the alterations would need to
meet code in that specific area but you
would not have to bring the whole
building up to code
representative walls thank you question
for you
um on some of these older subdivisions
or any of the the developers that are
still building them building the
buildings to the old
code or are they building modern
buildings on these Lots
if you can answer that yes in the
subdivisions that I've been involved
with they are building to the modern
code because that is the what they're
applying for at the time of application
for a building permit
so unlike
land use regulations where you may have
the determination of substantial
completion and vested rights the
building and fire codes don't have that
which and again I I believe is the right
path because of the advances that come
from
into the building codes from natural
disasters from
develop improvements to products in the
construction industry new methods of
constructing all of this keeps evolving
and I think we need to keep up with that
evolution
would you be comfortable with uh let's
take a 19 mid 1970s subdivision approval
that may have
non-conforming lots by today's
ordinances but they're using modern
building uh building practices would you
be comfortable with language that would
leave the uh
the subdivision lot sizes or whatever
those conditions might be the way they
are but modern uh building techniques
I don't see where that would be a
problem the building codes are a lot
less stringent on building lot sizes and
uh lot line uh separations and setbacks
the building code doesn't recognize that
and we'll in most cases will allow you
to build as close as three feet to a
property line where most local zoning
regulations do not correct
but representative De Lorenzo thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question I I'm wondering um how much
financing and insurance
our factor in the building Renovations
that are allowed
you know for um
70s style properties
I would have to defer to someone that is
much more knowledgeable in the banking
industry and the insurance industry than
I but I would suspect that
um not building to a more current
building code the insurance companies
might not look upon that fondly also we
need to also remember that you know um
FEMA who is you know a Federal
Regulation
um if there's any federal money involved
in any rebuilding or reconstructing of
these subdivisions they would have to be
built to the most current code directed
by FEMA so there's there's a lot of
federal requirements as well as state
requirements involved here but yes I I
do suspect the insurance industry and
the lenders would have an issue with a
building not to current code
may I follow up yes and that brings to
mind the recent flooding that we've had
in New Hampshire how much is that going
to affect changing the code to meet the
current conditions
older building codes did not recognize
floodplains such as the newer codes do
construction in flood Plains is often
permitted provided the building is is
built to with built and designed to um
accommodate the potential for a flood a
flooded basement such as your mechanical
equipment your electrical equipment
would be somewhere in your house above
flood stage but you could still build
there uh prior codes did not recognize
that and you could actually put all of
your systems in the basement where they
would be flooded
representative Walsh thank you Mr chair
and if you're going to be working with
Mr Frost and and representative Wallace
I'll ask the question would you be
opposed to I think a shorter period
of grandfathering of codes
then say your example of a subdivision
from seven years ago and and I ask you
this and I'll give you an example why
because this just happened to me
recently a couple of constituents in my
town built their houses based on the
approved plan
subdivision with a 14-foot driveway
under right at the time we were
operating under NFPA one 2015
um and section 18 which deals with fire
access roads did not mention anything
about residential driveways
it was only a year's time these people
finished their houses based on the
approved plans and the approved
ordinance built their driveways to spec
including all of their their uh uh
Wetlands Crossing and Des applications
and then a time of Co when they had no
more money left and the construction
loan was paid for or or done extended
the fire department said he wanted a
20-foot driveway instead of the 14 that
was by plan
so this is the type of thing that we
heard from a lot of developers that goes
on more often than you think so would
you be opposed to maybe a shorter
duration I mean that wasn't fair I think
I got to solved legislatively this year
but I'm sure it happens with other codes
can't speak for you know everyone in our
association I can speak for that you
know we're always open to negotiation
and compromise where we can find Common
Ground
um you know as I've also been told you
on the best negotiation is that
everybody walks away from the table
unhappy
um and so I absolutely we could look at
that and and consider a shorter time
frame I'd also
question
when a developer is
given that
type of situation is an appeals process
that they can go through they can appeal
the code official they can appeal to the
local they can also appeal to the state
and and I find often that developers are
leery of doing so because they don't
want to create a
a bad situation
So when you say appeal to the state that
would be the courts
or is it is it is there a board
that you have yes there's a current the
current process that was adopted uh I
believe
um two years ago two or three years ago
is you have a local appeals board which
which will address anything locally and
if you still feel aggrieved by the local
community you can appeal to the State
Building Code review board which which
is a 17 person 17 member Board of
various disciplines in the construction
industry engineering
land use codes that
that is what they do they just they eat
and sleep codes but they are absolutely
an appeal board you could bring a case
like that too for their determination of
whether the code was um
code was presented right whether whether
it was um you know uh
uh used correctly in that in that
certain instance
good
I'm having a hard time putting it to a
question
would you believe that when somebody has
to close on their construction loan they
don't have a time to go to an appeals
board
I can appreciate that
representative Cullen thank you I I do
um kind of agree with the sentiment that
that the
my main concern at least with this type
of legislation is the
um the local municipalities making
um rule changes that make
um previously approved Lots
non-conforming and having them have
additional
um barriers
having to go seek relief for from the
zba and stuff like that for
building
um an addition or whatever the case may
be that a a lot that is right next door
doesn't have because they they are
conforming
there's no other difference
um and I think that
that we in New Hampshire have have a lot
of properties that are now
non-conforming which were completely
legitimately formed
um to the conforming uh to the the
standards as they were at the time
um
of creation and so I think that you know
whether or not we we grandfather
additional building codes that I don't
think that is the main focus of my
um concern
um you know I being on a zba and having
someone have to come in for a shed being
placed you know 15 feet from the from
the property line
um when every other
house on the street has a shed 15 feet
from the property line and so it just
doesn't make any sense why they are
singled out because they they're you
know
they're non-conforming and they have to
go and pay you know the zba fees and the
notification fees and all of that stuff
is just a barrier unnecessary created by
the the
municipality I think unjustly and so
that's mostly what I'm trying to or
mostly I'm concerned about
from my perspective was that a question
for Bill or is
um
I mean I'm just uh yeah I guess I don't
I don't really have a question I think I
am agreeing a little bit with the the
sentiment that maybe it isn't the
building code that that is the like the
the focus or shouldn't be necessarily
the focus of this I do I guess have a
question about the the example that
representative Walsh made about the
um Fire official if the code review
board is the
would be able to accept uh an appeal of
a fire official's decision
um because
are they really a code review or is it
really within that jurisdiction
yes the building code review board has
the has has the authority to hear
appeals of the building and fire codes
for the State of New Hampshire
and the authority to override
to make a determination of whether the
code was correctly applied or not okay
they can't they can't Grant waivers to
code but what they can do is make a
determination of whether the code
official you know apply the code
correctly in that instance
so so there yeah what would be the
consequence of a ruling
if it was incorrect as determined by the
the State Board
would the decision be reversed yes the
decision would would be recommended to
be reversed recommended or would it be
reversed I I'll be honest with you I
don't serve on the building code uh
review board I don't know their exact
Authority you know authority over
governing what
I only ask because I also have a piece
of legislation that would direct a lot
of these appeals to go to the housing
appeals board which does have the
authority so I guess my question is
does your board have the authority to do
this already and have the teeth behind
it to override these decisions or or not
override but change change a ruling
I do ever representative building code
review that would be awesome thank you
good morning uh Phil Sherman the chair
of the building code review board
couldn't make it today so I'm a
representative uh Michael Hagen I sit on
the building code review board
um
I guess to answer your question uh it is
a um uh it is an official ruling it is a
uh
um there it is overseen almost as a um I
I don't want to quote this wrong but it
does have the authority to as a decision
um that uh I don't want to say
um
I know I'm going to get the wording
wrong so I'm not going to say it but it
does have the authority that that is the
final decision now the process the next
process would be they can appeal to
Superior Court if they don't agree with
it either in favor of the developer for
their question or the municipality they
could appeal it to Superior or vice
versa so there is that last step that
doesn't take away the authority to still
bring it to Superior Court
if they want to appeal that this that
final decision
I'm okay
representative thank you do you have
um do you have jurisdiction over
um
only local uh municipality decisions or
whatever what if the Des or or the State
Fire Marshal made a decision would you
be able to appeal those same things to
your board and you could overrule those
those ones also only pertaining to the
State Building Code and fire code so the
the example I'm sorry the example that
representative Walsh said with the
driveway that would be something that
your board would deal with so first
appeal for that would be they would
appeal it or ask for either a waiver or
variance from the State Farm Marshal
because they can give waivers and
variances to the state fire code that
would be your first process if they
don't agree with it then it would be
then the state if they don't agree with
that decision it would come to the
building code review board um
after that process
okay
um does anyone else have questions
representative birdie
thank you Mr chairman
um in the case of the driveway when a
plan is approved whether it's a subsidy
it's a subdivision it's going to be
approved by the town and they consider a
lot of things the construction of the
house all the codes in the house
the roads
turnarounds for fire engines and all
that why wouldn't the driveway be potted
a permitting process
when you have a plot plan with a house
everything is approved why isn't the
driveway approved at the same time and
why doesn't the fire department sign off
on that plan
I think I go ahead and represent Wall
Street
well they were first of all the
subdivision in question did go through a
technical Review Committee it was also
reviewed by our engineer with the
driveways on it that it complied with
our ordinance that's what the shocking
part about it was when the ordinance
says 14 feet and then the Marshall comes
in at time of sending the chief comes in
at Co time and says no I decided I want
20. that's what started all this and
that's the type of thing that people
don't deserve to have and hopefully we
can find some language that stops IT in
the future
okay but to alleviate the problem you
think the fire department should sign
off on a plan before it's built
they do yeah
so that shouldn't have that well they
are given the opportunity but in this
particular case I guess they didn't
attend the Tia technical Review
Committee so they had a window to chime
in they did not chime in because they
didn't it went through the rest of the
process as they always do and then at
the end of the day he came back and said
no I want six feet wider which would
have required more culverts more DDS
permits etc etc and to be honest with
you the the NFPA won 2018 was just got
adopted hadn't been adopted yet but he
knew it was coming that's why he decided
to expand his interpretation of what the
fire access road was and apply it to
driveways for residential purposes so
this is that is precisely what this this
language is trying to do so I I'm really
hoping that we can get air to address
something like that thank you very much
for your Insight
all right is there anything else on this
so representative what about just
forbidding
requiring things that are greater than
them than the code if you're if you're
are or the greater than what is what is
currently in statute if you're or in the
zoning ordinance right the the adopted
um
width of the driveway was approved and
allowed and if a if
official comes in and says I want more
than that
then that is not within his authority to
do is my opinion and so why couldn't we
just disallow that action if it's
already not disallowed because I think
it should be I think the code was
changed I think in this situation it was
changed right representative Walsh in
between I didn't get a law pass and
signed by the governor to address the
specific issue but that that's that
whole concept could happen with a lot of
other codes okay
great so um representative Wallace you
are going to consult with yes our
friends in the room and make sure we can
get some language here on this
okay
um the next one I want to move on to
while we're here because I brought it up
is the language that I have that would
amend the RSA around the housing appeals
board so there is um I pass around
language to the committee there is
um extras on the table out back but to
present this this is I believe
a small expansion that addresses
um problems relating to private property
rights
it adds one sentence that said that
gives jurisdiction to the housing
appeals board to address appeals related
to State issue permanent or licenses
related to housing and Housing
Development only so this goes to part of
what we talked about with building code
but it expands it to rulings made by do
you need one
this is the one about Amanda RSA 679 by
so this goes to any rulings from uh or
any rules from Des
State Fire Marshal's Office anything
that
um could hinder development it could be
appealed through this board
um so with that I love the committee's
feedback on this and and see where
everybody everybody's heads up
thank you
um I I think that it's
good
um I also just kind of Wonder
um about if this
we just heard about the the
um code review board and I'm just
wondering about if this has a similar
type of time frame as far as like wood
wood people if this change happened if
this this board has a tighter window of
of making decisions and stuff like that
maybe
um people end up going to this way
instead of the review board if it would
result in a faster decision
um but I also think that you know there
are things that may not come under the
specifically under the code language
that that need to be addressed and so
um I guess
uh I would support it
um I think that
I'm just wondering if if the
the things heard by the
um the appeals board are they
um kind of like how you think of um in
the court system where it's like
precedent like if you if someone else
comes with the exact same claim they're
gonna get the same result whereas in the
zba like you're not just because one of
them got approved doesn't mean the next
one is going to get approved kind of a
thing the housing appeals board is is
part of the judicial branch okay um they
would address and make rules I'm Ben's
looking at me dude so he's having a
heart but they would they would address
these things and make rulings on it so
I think you might want comment
this this would just provide another
option for somebody that feels aggrieved
during the um process and this would
address state only so this would not do
anything to override local
municipalities
um it would just expand it to uh state
issued permits or licenses
representative Walsh yeah hi thank you
Mr chair
um do they have the the
background for these types of questions
permits and licenses as opposed to if
you read their charges basically land
use law that they deal with
have you is anybody inquired on that I
don't know if they have the expertise of
my question that that is what I
there there was a concern that they
didn't have the the subject matter
expertise there so
they have the expertise around
um
housing and Housing Development so I
think I we could stretch it to say that
this impedes the development or private
property rights I I would say that
they should have it
um but that's a good question
go ahead yeah follow up
um on the actual change itself to the
statute do we want to limit it to
permits or licenses related to housing
and Housing Development
or could we just say
here appeals related to state issues
permanences permits or licenses period
in other words why is you could have the
same issues with the commercial
development as well
just a thought that would I mean that
would definitely go outside the purview
of the housing appeals board who would
address this housing only issues so
that's why we left that language in
there
would you like to weigh in sure
foreign
thank you Mr chair uh Michael Hagan
representing the building code review
board
um currently the you're saying state
permits issued
um if I found the section RSA
um a11 for the appeals decisions for the
State Fire Marshal that specifically
States in there and a lot of
municipalities use this State Fire
Marshal's Office for building permits so
my question would be is if you put this
in this section as well they have to go
to that appeals board as well as the
building code review review board for
appeals did you see how they can make
conflict on each other and they might
have to go two paths to get a decision
and which one would rule on on the final
decision so so my question when I that's
why I asked you
um does your board have the teeth to
actually make the ruling and
I know this board does I didn't get a
clear answer from you whether your board
did
it does that make sense it is a final
decision so it would overrule the local
zoning it would overrule the local
um building official or State Farm
Marshall's office this would be the the
final decision that then again could be
appealed to Spirit core there's still
that final path and does your board also
set precedent with with some of these
things are these are these decisions
able to be made in the superior court
and cited
as president
I could not answer that question
um but the Attorney General's office
could answer that question that we do
one does sit on our board for these
specific hearings
um as a representative for the board so
representative
yeah thanks Mr chair can you repeat what
you said about issuing the issuance of
building permits did you say that my
fire marshal office does that as well so
under RSA 674
um local municipalities have to enfor
have to adopt an enforcement mechanism
in order to enforce the State Building
Code if they don't have the means or or
um
or anybody to take on the job they can
have uh under that Authority have the
State Fire Marshal's Office issue
building permits under their system uh I
believe right now Claremont uses them
for a commercial uh buildings
at this time so they in order to get a
commercial building permit you go to
State Farm Marshall's office you submit
for your permit application they review
it and do inspections
how often is it housing like so how
often do you have a I mean does the
State Farm Marshall's office deal with a
lot of the housing permit code that
would be a question for the State Farm
Marshall I couldn't answer that thank
you
representative Kelly thank you but
um I think that your your point was that
they do like whether that be
municipalities issuing or the State Fire
Marshal issuing the appeals process is
what you were trying to
clarify right is that the appeals
process is X right now and maybe we're
adding an additional y to the process
and it isn't necessarily that they are
going to have to go to both maybe they
could choose which one they go to
um it seems like because under the
language that he's proposing it says may
right and so may go to this board if the
other one also says may then they could
essentially choose which board they want
to hear the appeal maybe something like
the speed of decisions might be a factor
in whether or not they choose one or the
other what what are your
um can you explain a little bit more
about your understanding of the process
of the appeals from the
um the the
[Music]
decisions of the Fire Marshals
um you know sure I can read it right
from the RCA if if you'd like uh it's
RSA again 155 a11 appeals of decision
for the State Fire Marshal 2 which is
the process the board shall hold a
hearing within 40 days of receipt of the
complaint unless extension of time has
been granted by the board at a written
request of one of the parties and shall
render a decision within 30 days of the
conclusion of the hearing
housing appeals board has
to make a decision
it's a total of 150 days from the filing
of an appeal thank you
um so another question if
there's a puddle in my on my property
and it's ruled as a wetland is your
board allowed to render a decision
it is not okay I I'm not I'm not 100
sure on that but I I can 99.9 guarantee
we cannot hear it uh it's specific in
that RSA 11 12 and 13 what what we can
hear appeals on okay so so this would
dovetail perfectly with your board to
allow options for a private property
owner to choose where to appeal
a state issued permit decision
that's up for you to decide
is there anything else on this area okay
how's the committee feel about this
in agreement
okay I'm going to file this LSR and I'll
include the whole family um the whole
committee
yeah okay
okay so next on the agenda I want to
bring in Des and I want to call on
representative McConkey to kind of kick
us off
thank you yep thank you chair and
Alexander
um I um I have a report here
I haven't gotten quite as far as other
members have with draft legislation but
I'm uh soon to be there and I I
apologize to the representatives on the
end I have it available online I'm short
by two copies of this but I'll read my
testimony
I explored two reoccurring themes that
we discussed here in committee first
being that the New Hampshire Department
of Environmental Services was out of
touch with daily design flows water
usage
as it appears that our numbers are
higher than our neighboring states are
our numbers based in science
secondly if we lower the required area
for an on-site septic system
wouldn't subdivision lot sizing also be
reduced yielding higher density or more
units per acre
I started by comparing New Hampshire
subsurface regulations to those in Maine
two states that I have designed
experience in
New Hampshire used a design flow of 150
gallons per day for each bedroom while
Maine only uses 90 gallons per day flow
rate
so on the surface main lot loading
requirement is 40 percent less than ours
so that must equate to smaller septic
system requirements
there is a second factor in septic
design and that is to consider the soil
itself and for Simplicity let's call the
quality of the native soil as great good
or poor
and finally in an attempt to keep the
comparison realistic I chose a stone and
pipe leech field which is the old tried
and true system used in both of these
states
I have enclosed a chart for this
comparison and I will run the numbers
but basically despite the deci design
flow being 40 percent higher in New
Hampshire the system size is most cases
is similar or smaller in New Hampshire
than in Maine
in closed I have a sheet that talks
about best average and bad soil
in Maine the best soil New Hampshire is
actually a 142 square foot lesson size
on average soil New Hampshire is all but
64 square feet larger than Maine
and in poor or bad soil New Hampshire is
40 percent or 40 square feet less than
that in Maine
the state did take a lesser design flow
in response to senior housing a number
of years ago and adjusted the daily flow
rate from 150 gallons per bedroom to I
believe it's 125 presently
the premise was that older adults 65
years of age are less active and would
use less water
sounds right on the surface but the
definition of adult has has been reduced
now to 55 and older communities and now
yet another person can live there also
As a caretaker
the drop in age did not carry through on
the original premise of less active
population
and the southern area of our state I
understand it's beginning to experience
a higher than typical septic failure
rate and that's because there's more
water than they ever anticipated more
water more sewer it doesn't hold up
so what is the science behind our flow
rates
in 2003 the Society of soil scientists
of Northern New England commissioned a
study to look at soil-based lot sizing
and I have a copy of
of that sheet in in my report that's
here
when this highly anticipated planning
document was completed it demonstrated
that many New Hampshire towns were
calling for larger lot sizes than the
science suggested
but when we looked at the state it was
generally in line with their findings
and the Des subsurface did not adjust
their lot sizing
what the state has learned is that water
usage is ever evolving and the best tool
for sizing systems is to use metered
flow
using similar uses based on a number of
persons occupying a space ideally over a
year's time and then multiplying that
flow by a factor of one or two depending
on the type of strength of waste in
addition flow Factor takes into account
periods of high use example in the
morning when everyone gets up in showers
makes breakfast or days multiple wash
loads or extended guest visits that
create larger flow that the system must
absorb quickly so that the extra
capacity in the design flow adds to the
system's longevity as opposed to when I
spoke to the senior housing that it
caused a premature failure
what I don't suggest while I don't
suggest a wholesale adjustment to our
daily flow rates at this time I do
suggest that we legislate changes to
construction requirements for effluent
disposal areas Eda most people would
refer to as a septic system
without getting too technical the
determination of whether a septic system
can be constructed in ground or if the
system will need to be mounded and have
a pump is is by the depth of the
seasonal high water table shwt
presently the standard for traditional
construction is four feet above that
marker
but in the event of a failure the design
standard is reduced to only two feet
above seasonal high water
New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services subsurface has
Decades of results that replacement
traditional septic systems Stone and
pipe chamber system and others function
every bit as well at that elevation as
those constructed at the four foot
marker two foot higher
I suggest this change in itself will
permit the cost of develop of a
developed lot to be greatly reduced with
no ill effect on the environment
I'm working on language and I believe I
will have a buy-in
I will have Department buy and providing
a six inch layer of sand under the
system is added to further Safeguard the
aquifer
if you can if you can construct
in-ground without the need of pump
Chambers pumps alarms electricians to
tie in the required components
the homeowner or and or the developer
can realize the savings of a thousands
of dollars per system thousands not
hundreds
I offer this report based on my 30 years
of septic design install practice
my research of soil based data and
conversations with the power
Environmental Services
subsurface personnel and I submit to you
this Mr chairman for your consideration
well thank you very much that's very
detailed that certain some of that
certainly went over my head but I
believe you know well I've got two
exercises
to weigh in on this is there anything
from the committee before I call on Des
uh representative Reed
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for this work and also I
saw that the researchers sent us the
soil based lot sizing report that you
requested I haven't read it yet but um
thank you for doing that
um one of the things we heard in a
presentation which now
I don't know if it was DS I think it was
somebody else had presented to us was
talking about the technological
developments
um with these systems that that have
increasingly reduced the need for
um land um to far far less than what
many of our municipality uh lot minimums
are it sounds like from your report it's
already even in the poorest soil we're
talking about a need of
13 1400 square feet so obviously
municipalities that have 20 acre lot
minimums are way way out of of touch
with
specifically with with that being a
Cause
um is there do you see and you you know
the technology better
um any way to maybe include in proposed
legislation a a tie-in to technology
available so that it's technology
dependent
thank you thank you for the question
I I started in thinking the same way you
are and I have
Fair experience with Innovative
technology
that is approved by the state and
reviewed and approved by Des
and I and it does provide a wonderful
opportunity in certain instances to put
a system back on the lot that was sub
subsized the 70s subdivision question
a property that now is in existence and
has a grandfathered right for a much
larger use on a property
um and um so at Last Resort we always
try and grow traditional Last Resort
that works fine
um I think we are I think we need to do
more work
on long-term studies and making sure
that once these systems are put in place
that they continue to perform the way
they started out many of the systems
have a
have you have to assign a service
contract so an agent of the of the
technological company comes out and
ensures that it's running properly but
quite honestly it doesn't appear that
there is much study continuing to make
sure that they're functioning at the
level they did when they first started
so where I thought we should allow
lot sizing to become smaller if we use
more technology I don't think we're
there yet
thank you and it again it looks like
even everything but inner city Lots
wouldn't really be impacted in terms of
a water need based on the numbers you
have here is that correct and I'm sorry
Mr chair I didn't ask for the follow-up
ah
inner city Lots being obviously
typically on Municipal Water so when you
when even in the worst worst possible
soil we're looking at 1300 square feet
required that's only going to impact a
very very small lot anything a half acre
or larger can easily accommodate that
right and so I would tend to agree if we
knew what their water supply was
okay
would someone from Des please come up
and give us feedback on this and let us
know where you're at on this legislation
or prospective legislation
good morning for the record I'm Phil
Trowbridge manager of the land resource
management programs at DES
cription yeah for the record I'm the
director of The Water Division at DES
welcome back
well thanks
so okay just for to start out thank you
representative McConkey for your
detailed report
certainly something that we would take
an interest in uh we'd like to obviously
see the specific language before you
know weighing into too much but this is
something that we've discussed
uh internally and the points that
representative McConkey made are
valid and appropriate
yeah and I think uh unlike uh
representative McConkey I've been
involved in well I've been at the state
for 50 years so you can imagine
um I was there basically the beginning
of septic systems so I've seen that as
it's grown I've seen as we've looked at
Innovative Technologies and I would
agree with representative McConkey that
you know unfortunately Des has no money
and has never been able to budget for r
d work and I think the suggestions that
representative McConkey made sense you
know it would be nice if we had staff
available to do some r d work sample
monitoring see what we've permitted
innovatively and see if in fact it is
effective what you have to keep in mind
is when you're talking about Wastewater
loading or
site learning that you're talking about
over the years you know 65 percent of
the state when you look at the
populations on Municipal Water and
Wastewater the other fit 45 50 percent
are on septic systems historically based
on a lot sizes and our loading based on
150 gallons per day albeit in some cases
is conservative in my career I have
never seen a Bedrock well that's been
polluted by an on-site sepsis system so
one can come to two conclusions out of
that that one that the soil is being
effective and efficient or number two
that uh hydraulic loading 150 gallons
per day per bedroom has been albeit on
its faces
conservative seems to be doing the job
as you may or may not know most sites
whether you're looking at a two-bedroom
house three-bedroom four-bedroom house
based on the soil's capability that
actively renovate the Wastewater and on
that site you probably have an
individual well where you subtract that
radius so you have enough movement in
the groundwater for that to be treated
before it gets to the well
so albeit I think it it may be time to
think about per gallons per day use for
whatever the facility is I think I want
to caution the committee that what we're
seeing now is increased failures and I
think representative McConkey mentioned
that and today the world has changed you
know we've got a lot more people moving
back into homes we've got multiple uses
now the two people living in a
three-bedroom house has now gone back to
four five six we're seeing a result of
the the increase in the number of failed
septic systems over the last two years
more so than what we've seen in the past
I think a lot of that's done to what we
call overloaded hydraulically there's
more flows going into the systems that
they perhaps in many cases were designed
to so my caution would be that we walk
before we run and think about the
concepts I think what representative
McConkey talked on the stone and pipe I
think it's time that we look at two feet
above seasonal high water table for that
it's it makes sense being in the
business as long as I've been what's
actively doing a lot of the work on an
on-site Wastewater system is the sand
beneath whatever that
system is designed to be whether it be
an Innovative technology or whether it
be Stone and pipe so I mean I think
that's something right as I sit here
today we would certainly actively
support it makes a lot of sense we have
used sand as treatment for drinking
water for years and years and years it's
an effective media and it does a pretty
good job so I certainly would commit
today that we we can
clearly support that kind of concept
because I think it makes a lot of sense
and it has probably for many years but I
guess the rest of it be interested to
see what the formal or the final
language looks like of the draft
language and if it's something that that
makes sense with our experience over
time then I think we certainly would be
willing to comment or participate or
whatever but you know we're we're not
ever against change you know I think
it's just got to be methodical and it's
going to be scientifically based and uh
if those two things meet the criteria I
say we all move forward makes sense
great I mean I'm looking at
thousands of of dollars saved per system
is going to be a huge huge huge
alleviation for developers especially if
they're building large properties so
thank you for helping us buy in and I
have commitment from the speaker that
these bills are going to come to our
committee so we're going to be able to
um continue this conversation so we will
definitely see you back for this
representative
thank you
um are you familiar with the
um these
uh 2003 soil based lot sizing
um report that was mentioned and uh
referenced in in representative
mcconkey's uh
statement and
um and specifically about their
um in that there is some suggestions
based on soil type of the the
recommended minimum lot sizes
um are you familiar with those what are
your
thoughts on them if any and um does the
department have some of their own kind
of like uh maybe requirements for a lot
um that let's say services like has
um
uh it's its requirements
um based on soil type of let's say A you
know a septic and water system
um for uh residential
do they have do you guys have some like
uh maybe a chart that says you know you
you're going to need this much land to
be able to fulfill our requirements or
something like that
um that you could provide the committee
thanks
thank you representative yukela I can I
can answer your question yes we in fact
have uh exactly the chart that you're
asking for that establishes the the size
of or the area of land needed to treat
the waste based on the soil type the
slope of the land and then also you have
to cut out uh you know the area the
radius around of drinking water well or
Wetland areas and that tells you you
know the how much treatable soil or soil
for treatment you have on your lot
um we the um the 2003 report that
representative McConkey mentioned
provided a table like this related to
soil type and slope and provided these
certain minimum areas for treatment
we have the exact same table in our
regulations and our our areas are almost
the same they're a little bit uh smaller
so it's a little bit less restrictive
but they are you know within five
percent of each other so um we're very
much in line with the recommendations
from the soil scientists
and one of the things I like to mention
when talking about septic systems and
housing
um is geology is Destiny right the
ability to put houses on land depends on
the type of property you have uh how how
type of soil you have how deep you are
to bedrock how much Wetland you have
Etc uh so um the same size Lots can
handle different amounts of housing
units depending on the geology of it and
we do those calculations or developers
do those calculations then submit submit
to us for review when they are
subdividing properties or they are
developing them and that's a very well
established process already in
administrative role
bye are you aware of any municipalities
that are using
um
those suggestions
um and basing their
um their minimum lot sizes much in the
same way that you suggest or have that
have those suggestions been pretty much
like pushed to the Wayside and and
they've gone their own path in your
experience
yeah I think as as you're you're all
aware municipalities have the ability to
be more strict than Des but it can't be
less more lenient I think there's two
facets that I've seen in my career that
regulate lot sizes and what's developed
in town some are scientifically based
and they look to conscribe to what we do
for light a lot of them are just social
implications a lot of times they just
want to wake as a zoning that's the way
they want their town to look like you
know and if the vote is weigh in on that
and that's what the people who live
there choosing so be it that's something
that we don't have regulatory authority
over but I think it the common sense
that we've utilized over certainly many
years is is that
we we try and stay away from the social
implications all we want to do is make
sure that if someone develops a site
whether it be commercial residential
condos that this sustainability so
they're going to have portable drinking
water for the for the life of that site
and also we won't be generating waste
that isn't treated so it in it is an
encroachment on a rivers lakes and ponds
so that's that's kind of where we stay
we stay out of the social implications
we look at the scientific
results of what development's doing
thank you you mentioned that you're you
had these suggestions in your
regulations do you happen to know the
regulation or could you provide a copy
of that to the to the committee
um offhand
sure well
um yeah so the the minimum lot size is
it's in the subsurface rules which is
envwq 1005.
and you'll see in that section there's a
table it's 1005-1
and that has that chart
okay
okay can I get your feedback on the bill
that uh
the the language that I added to that
the
the structure of the housing appeals
board can I get your feedback on that
all right I'll start out and then all
right the the one thing I would just uh
want to mention is there is also a
separate appeals board for Des decisions
uh there's the wetlands Council uh
there's so many appeal Sports yeah and
there's also a Waters Council water
Council which here's appeals related to
subsurface decisions so the same
questions that came up as to
you know which appeals board they might
go through
um I would have those same questions
about your proposal
um the wetlands Council has the full
authority to reverse or remand a
decision by the department
if someone if the
um the decisions of the council can be
then appealed to Superior Supreme Court
um so um you know there already is a
pretty strict process and and pretty
fast timelines for appealing on a
decision by the department either on a
Wetlands an alteration of terrain or a
subsurface decision
okay thank you
all right anybody else for Des
thank you very much much appreciated and
thank you representative McConkey on for
taking the lead on this uh so moving
forward I'm gonna have you send us
hopefully some legislation the next week
or so so we can look into this and um
get this proposed for this year yes
thank you thank you
okay uh the next one I have I'm going to
dive into impact fees
um so this is
hopefully going to
um give more flexibility to developers
to negotiate and impact fee schedule and
municipalities to hold on to back piece
for longer does everyone have the paper
that I passed around
perfect so
um this is
here I have another one
it's on the table as well this would it
makes
two it makes a small change it basically
allows the municipality to hold on to
impact fees from six years to ten years
um it allows
further negotiation between a developer
and municipalities and more flexibility
so this is something we heard from
developers and from municipalities I
believe the city of Manchester came in
planning department and said for
development that takes more than six
years we'd like the ability
um to hold on to these fees a little
longer to allow more flexibility so uh
with that I'll take questions from the
committee but I feel like this is pretty
straightforward this one
um
is hopefully a low hanging fruit go
ahead representative
thank you Mr
um
I just have a question about the the
change about the um
the refund gets paid to the
um
the one the one who owns that the payer
or the pay successor and interest is is
there additional language that should be
in Brackets so that or is is
is the actual current language shall be
made to the payers pay successor of
Interest then current property owner
this is this would be the changes so
this is an OLS that drafted this this is
uh right is in current language the then
current property owner actually in in
the no it's repair pays successor and
interest that would get scratched
and it would be replaced with then
current property owner okay so it would
have been yeah like a bracket around
that would have yes or bold or something
um okay
so
I'm just wondering about the effects of
switching from the person that paid in
the money getting refunded the money
versus whoever paid in the money now
sold that to someone else
um and then that person is going to get
the refund I'm just wondering about is
in all is this change because right now
it's hard for the
um those people that are buying the
property to
um like take over the
ownership of those improvements or or
something like that or that those when
they buy the property they're required
to
um like I don't understand why this
change needs to happen and what are the
what are the like
negative consequences that could be
um
occur because like we have this setup of
of you know the developer paid in the
money and they expected that money and
that went into the cost of the the
development or whatever and now
um
they're expecting to get that money back
but and so maybe they're not including
that in the cost of the development
right now but then they are and so can
you kind of explain to answer your
question there's there's really nothing
stopping a developer and municipality to
have a contract and there's nothing
stopping a contract happening between
the developer who paid the impact fees
and the person they sold it to to
send the money to them there's nothing
stopping that the the money would go to
the current the current property owner
when it was given back and that's only
after they sold the property so a lot of
times they don't sell the property or
the development takes longer than six
years they're still holding on to it so
um this would just give more flexibility
to a municipality who has a a
development that takes longer than the
six years because that was a that was
what Manchester said they ran into
yeah follow-up yep I I guess I don't not
I I think you're more addressing the six
versus ten year thing you're answering
that and not really my question my
question since it seems like they'll pay
your own pay your successor of the in in
success or in interest
um seems to be like the payer successor
and interest may be the successor of
interest in the property and therefore
is already the person that buys the
property afterwards and so changing it
to the successor's successor and
interest in replacing that with a
property owner is essentially just
saying the exact same thing again
um or
are you or
if it the payer or the payer's success
or if interest it may be the person that
paid in the money and then they when
they sell as part of the contract they
say you're gonna get the refund but now
we're saying in law that it's going to
go to that person and and essentially
barring them from having a contract that
says no I'm going to give you a let
lower price and I'm gonna get the refund
if if those
those improvements aren't
aren't made and the money isn't used so
I'm gonna get that refund it sounds like
it's possible that this language is more
restrictive than is currently allowed
I'm not 100 sure so can you speak to
that I'm gonna allow would you like to
weigh in Ben and let me know why you
include that language I I see where
you're coming from with that too
um but I'm gonna let Ben weigh in
thank you Mr chairman Ben Frost from New
Hampshire housing I think this is a a
really good discussion and it goes
back I think it was 2006 when this
statute was amended and I have to
confess
that the the language pay or or payers
success or an interest was language that
I drafted way back then and I thought I
knew what it meant then
but then it was subject to a
dispute in Pelham that wound up before
the New Hampshire Supreme Court trying
to figure out what that language meant
and it was there was ambiguity here uh
and I this what is proposed here is an
attempt to
make it Crystal Clear who gets the money
back uh it's a
I don't want to say universally but in
most cases where an impact fee is paid
that becomes a cost of the development
and so it gets passed on to whoever the
end user is of that property whether it
is the developer themselves if they if
they retain ownership as my often is in
the case with commercial development
or in a subdivision it's the property
owners in a subdivision so they've in
effect that the buyer is in a
subdivision have paid the cost of that
impact fee
so then they should get that money back
if it is not used by the municipality
so that that's the thinking behind this
change and I'll note that this is
something that I simply propose to the
the chairman of the city of Manchester
simply requested the change from six to
ten years
I will note
that as drafted this is incomplete there
are two places where this change needs
to be made this is
um RSA 674 21 5 J
deals not with impact fees but with
off-site exections in where there is not
an impact fee ordinance
the statute dealing with impact fees is
the same is the same statute
674-21.5 but uh sub paragraph e
is the one that deals with impact fees
and and the change six to ten also needs
to be made there
okay so that can be made when we go to
drafting
representative Keller
thank you for that explanation what um
if you know
what if you know was the Supreme Court's
interpretation of your language and
um and it it makes sense that if they
interpreted it in
um
let's say creative ways that we come
back and uh
clarify that that language thank you
thank you for that question I
um I I'm
trying to recall my recollection is that
the Supreme Court interpreted it to mean
in the context of pelham's regulations
uh they interpreted it to mean the
developer
even though the developer might not
necessarily have been the current owner
of the property and that was the the
essence of this dispute uh so I I recall
being surprised by the decision and then
reading it thinking well well okay yeah
there's ambiguity there
represent walls thank you Mr chair Mr
question I have
um
I'm fine with the successor of Interest
I understand all that thank you Mr Frost
but on the six to ten years
um
from the date of collection usually if
not always the impact fees are collected
as part of a condition to get the
approved to get the plans approved and
signed off by by the planning board
I and if our goal is to try to
encourage development I don't know how
allowing the municipalities to hold on
to the developers capital for an
additional four years is helping that
goal now maybe you want to say something
like six years after completion because
I get it some some things do take longer
than the six years but it's just to to
for the municipality to hold on to
developers working capital for an
additional four years doesn't seem to be
meeting the goals of what we're trying
to do just a thought yep six years after
completion I mean if a project takes
six years and then they can hold another
six years that's 12 years so
yeah no I I know I'm I'm
spitballing too so do you have anything
for us on that thank you Mr chairman and
I'll just note that I'm kind of arguing
against interest here
um typically I'm I'm speaking for uh the
development side of the table but I'm
also a land use planner I've worked uh
four municipalities as a planner as a
Town Administrator as a director of a
regional Planning Commission so I really
get the municipal side of things and
there are projects and this is what we
heard from the city of Manchester when
the planning director addressed you
several months ago there are projects
that the municipalities are doing for
which they're collecting impact fees
that take longer than six years
it takes longer for them to get them
done in in order for them to be able to
spend the impact fees and my sense is
that the developers are already putting
up this money anyway and it's not really
terribly material whether it's held by
the municipality for six or ten years
it's part of their their cost of
development
go ahead
let me ask you this
how many impact fees are actually
returned
that's an excellent question because if
they're never returned anyway I guess
the amount of years doesn't really
matter we've got um some research from
our committee researcher regarding that
I think I can
try to forward that to the committee I
don't think she looked into how often
they are returned but if there is a
developer in the room or somebody that
can help clarify that that'd be helpful
but
I I know for one in Pelham that that was
the subject of the uh the Supreme Court
decision
and I know also that this is not really
on point to your question but uh the
town of Londonderry was sued by at least
one developer may have been a couple uh
in the the town was required to return
something like 1.1 million dollars of
impact fees because they had not been
properly accounting for it
something to think about representative
Keller
I think
um thank you
um I think I have to agree with
representative Walsh that I'm not sure
that
um in
uh tying up the money for additional
time frame
um I think it is a little bit material
um in the sense that if you have that
money tied up for six years
um once you get it returned
theoretically you could put that money
towards the next project so if you're
doing multiple projects you're saying
you can build let's say
the difference between five projects
over 30 years versus three projects over
30 years using the same Capital
um the
the
um so there is that
um there also could be just the
um a change instead of to the time frame
just something along like
um
municipality that doesn't want to return
the money to the to the taxpayers May
encumber
funds that essentially sign a contract
I'm going to do XYZ project
I haven't completed it yet I haven't got
the final bill for it yet but I'm doing
that project and it is tied to this
money and therefore you could do we
could theoretically do something instead
of just extending the time frame it just
um maybe clarifying or I'm not seeing
anything that says like you can like
quote unquote encumber this money for
XYZ project that is currently like
proposed planned developed whatever the
case may be and so
um that money
is like designated to this project even
though the project isn't necessarily
completed within that six year window
if you get my drift so
representative I I do and I think that
that is at least in part already
addressed in statured so it it a
municipality May appropriate the funds
to do something
and that essentially secures that impact
fee from being returned
well thank you Miss Frost again
so I'm going to go back to the drawing
board with this and come back to the
committee if that works just to see if
we have something else that we can come
up with
um so I have a question for the
committee we have two more two more
things I would like to that's on my
agenda
um one is some dot standards a
conversation representative Walsh had
with um the director and then
um representative reads
um proposed legislation for adus do we
want to power through lunch or do we
want to break through lunch
representative
okay let's take let's take a 15-minute
break come back at 1205 and uh we will
power through lunch
thank you
foreign
committee on housing
um on my agenda doesn't mean there
aren't any other things on the agenda
but online I have two more things I'm
going to start with the I perceive to be
the faster one and I'm gonna call on
representative Walsh to kind of give us
an update on a meeting you had with the
Department of Transportation and
hopefully uh maybe some recommended
changes or
um
an update thank you
thank you Mr chair and um I'm not going
to apologize because it's still August
I'm not as far along as some either I
don't have recommended legislation or
even a report I just met with the uh
Department of Transportation this
morning would you like me to just go on
the Fly based on my notes okay
well if memory serves the reason that
the Department of Transportation or Road
way requirements came up was one of the
one of the
the presenters we had who was who
suggested I believe he was the one
talking about tiny homes and maybe the
roadways are you know prohibitive the
cost of roadways is prohibitive and
actually he was looking at dirt roads
um
so what I did with that is I spoke with
a couple of consultants and developers
and my my code enforcement officer
what I found without too much work was
that yes perhaps a lot of towns do use
the requirements for Department of
Transportation roadways as the accepted
accepted structure
um nobody knew of any that were actually
abusing it or using roadway requirements
as a way to deter development
the other side of the coin is too that
um I don't know what we can do
legislatively because any changes from
what's an accepted standard for a
roadway
once
I don't know who anybody would want to
go backwards you know after development
is completed the town actually where the
municipality takes ownership of the road
and I don't know of any that would want
to require substandard roadways because
who would want to rebuild them in five
years after a Project's complete so I
did not look up that tree much I didn't
find a problem as soon as I talked to
consultants and developers
if they had known of anybody that was
using this to try to deter nobody did
it's just an accepted cost however in my
experience I can tell you part of the
cost or what is contributing to a lot of
the cost of Roads
uh we've been debating this in Hooksett
for 12 years since I've been involved
probably longer right now we are not
requiring sidewalks and curbs and
sidewalks in subdivisions
that doesn't mean arterial roads that
doesn't mean Common Sense places and and
this is why I mean I couldn't get
anybody to say does sidewalks and curbs
double or triple the cost of a road
because every situation is different but
clearly it's a huge expense without
curbs and sidewalks you the rain water
storm water can actually sheet off
occasionally you might need a Swale but
it's all on the side of the road
relatively inexpensive the minute you
introduce curbs now you're introducing
all the infrastructure that goes below
it all your drainage structures or your
traps boxes piping etc etc so it you
don't even have to look at anecdotally
you can see it common sense obviously
it's a huge cost
they also don't last forever and once
you have sidewalks now with state law
that the town has to maintain them as
well including plowing so if you're
possibly looking at something to reduce
the prices of roadways maybe that's the
direction you would want to look by not
allowing them to mandate them where not
necessary I'll throw that out there what
we did in hooks it is we just made
adjustments in the road width and a
painted line and again this is not
something that I'd recommend on arterial
roads or any of your major you know
roadways but you're cul-de-sacs you're
small subdivisions that go nowhere
you're adding a heck of a lot of cost to
the town and the people that buy in that
because they have to pay for it by
introducing sidewalks that go nowhere in
most cases there's no connectivity
so I'll leave that alone because that's
why we even got dot involved in this in
the first place but I figured I'd go and
we'll look at a recommendation if you
even want to go down that that road
excuse the pun
uh but I did have a meeting with the
Department of Transportation this
morning with a goal of seeing how we
could possibly streamline reduce delays
which also reduce costs
and uh believe it or not they all the
questions I had for him
they've already started implementing so
and quickly I'll go through this
obviously the first thing we know and
again I've talked with some of the same
consultants and Developers
they admit there are delays those delays
can be expensive but they also
understand that like everybody else
according to dot they're looking at 20
to 30 percent
short-handed you know with Workforce we
all get that they're not using that as
an excuse but they're actually starting
to do some things that may help they are
currently introducing an electronic
permitting system because right now they
do not have any an applicant doesn't
have any way to track where his
application is uh within within the
department so they've already begun
uh implementing that
um they're also looking on another one
which did raise my eyes I think this one
is is hugely important in terms of
saving money in the long run
prior to them implementing a conceptual
approval
they needed 100 complete drawings before
they would take an application so that
means that the developer and the
engineer would have to come up with 100
submit them and if something didn't work
with the dot or for whatever reason then
they'd have to go back to the drawing
board and start over
by them getting into this 30 complete or
conceptual
they can have the conversation with the
D.O.T possibly get a conceptual approval
before they spend all the time and money
to finish the complete plan set
I think that's a huge step in the right
direction again they're already starting
to implement this
um
I mentioned too because we have I don't
know if you've ever seen it and I don't
have it presented but you can find it on
the dot website
the way that works is we have districts
throughout the state the two Southern
districts five and six obviously by
volume are the busiest and I did ask the
question and get the answer to the
affirmative
that joined the high volume seasons for
districts five and six they can and do
use some of the engineers and field
workers from the other slower districts
where lower volume districts to help
them catch up with a workload
in the process of that they're also
exploring the idea of doing a
centralized permitting process and
eliminating the need of doing it within
districts there's pros and cons to that
but it's something they're looking into
now
um but again I think with the the 30
conceptual that they've already started
to implement and the electronic
permitting system so that they can
actually have a tracking number if the
developer with the applicant to find out
what stages that are in can be a huge
help
uh again I I did not come out of there
with any eyebrow raising things that yes
we should legislate this uh but I did
ask the question uh one of the things
that the DOT
uh does now and it's voluntary with the
applicants as if if they're overwhelmed
uh they do give an applicant the
opportunity to hire their own peer
review engineer
for the approval process
and therefore cuts down their time they
can just review what somebody else did
because I didn't realize this they don't
have a permitting fee at the D.O.T right
now
so one of his suggestions if this
continues to be a problem would be the
entertain of an idea of allowing
the Department of Transportation to
collect fees for their permits
those are the only two things that as a
possibility to consider
and on my own if you're really looking
at reducing the cost of roadways and and
residential subdivisions eliminating
curbs and sidewalks were not needed
I'll leave it there
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Walsh representative Reed
uh thank you for that research
representative and I I tend to agree
with you that I think it makes more
sense in a lot of places to just expand
the width of a road I mean I'm going
back to the original Point expand the
width of a road and just have a
essentially a lane and I just wanted to
ask if you had asked about or was it
brought up because I've seen both in
Boston as well as Portsmouth and I don't
know the word for them but the tall
narrow like bumpers that in addition to
having a painted line basically offer
the level of protection that a curb
would offer so there's these Long Tall
sticks plastic sticks and they fold down
what are they called
delineators sure they fold down if a car
runs over them but it's a visual barrier
to prevent a car from swerving into that
uh bicycle slash walking Lane which
could also have extra benefit of
providing like an emergency pullover if
necessary in a pinch or you know for
emergency vehicles so I think that makes
a lot of sense
I don't know the name of them I did not
ask the question because I basically
envisioned just this in your quiet
residential areas
but if I did have to come up with a name
on my own I would say plow drivers
nightmare but well
represent McConkey
um thank you there was a bill that came
through Public Works last year I believe
or uh dot had made the suggestion that
they would like to move
to having a fee based permits so they
could do that so I can't remember what
the outcome was if we put it into uh to
study or not I've always been a huge
believer of painted painted lines on on
a road I like a little wider Road
there's a lot of calming happens
walkable communities
become better when you take the travel
way which is traditionally a 12 feet and
take it to 10 feet especially through
communities and secondary roads and it
gives the allusion to the driver that
they have to pay a little more attention
so then if you had a two foot shoulder
it now gives you a four foot shoulder a
lot of Road agents aren't as
enthusiastic as me but I always keep
putting it out there and it has it has a
basis and Truth
representative Damon
I just want to weigh in also with
support for the painted line as a
cyclist
um when you're biking where it's marked
drivers are notably more attentive and
courteous versus the same width Road
without a line
um there's a lot of territorial disputes
how I would put it and bikers don't win
I representative Walsh what have you um
I brought this up earlier but um how
would you feel about something about
like conditional permitting because I
guess so one of the costs for people
trying even you know me if I want to
build a driveway on my property or even
a developer is the time it takes for
these driveways to be these permits to
be issued
how would you feel about legislation
that would
approve
a permit
unless there was notification from dot
that they needed more time to evaluate
it
so I understand they're they're in a
staffing shortage maybe that's part of
the reason why they aren't approving
them as fast but one of the biggest
issues developers had was the time it
takes for some of these permits to be
approved I know Des does something
similar to what I'm proposing so what do
you think about that
um
at first approach I'm not opposed to
that at all and and for this reason
we've we've actually by law imposed time
limits on zoning and planning boards I
believe last year Des is currently doing
it
they do they have a time limit from
start from application drop off
is that what you just said
um I'm not opposed to it I'd like to do
a little more research on it to see what
number of days that would be effectively
again
one of the admissions I got today from
the Department was
all the problems that and they
understand what's going on but they're
not using the Manpower issue as a crutch
by any stretch
but right now all the solutions are
anecdotal they don't have any data of
their own and they're hoping that this
electronic permanent system will start
showing them where the problems really
are so
as much as I'm not opposed to what
you're saying I don't know if it's ready
you know what I mean I don't know what
basis we're putting that timeline on
without having any information that they
do currently so
um representative McConkey do you have
any information on Des the that
permitting
system the condition permitting through
Des or if you had something else to add
um I have something else but on Des
there are there are time limits on how
long they they must have they must turn
out a report by
um and uh it every time it creates
better and better efficiency and you
know to the benefit of the uh of our
residents there there is
um I'm not opposed to putting a time
limit on a driveway permit they may want
to be a two-tier process a simple
residential as opposed to a
a commercial operation I could see that
but from my my permitting that I've done
in several counties it's well known that
there are certain districts that will
turn out a report a permit much quicker
than the others and there are districts
that cause an awful lot of
more reporting to be done and mapping
and so forth so the point that
representative had mentioned next to me
that they will begin the process that's
positive but I don't think it hurts us
at all by imposing a number on that and
I think it's a good idea and and I think
you're right with the two-tiered system
I mean if we're looking at you know
single-family residential that just
wants you know a driveway in a different
spot I see no reason why the state is in
the way and hindering that you know and
if they need more time you can put in
the language say all you have to do is
send a letter that you need more time in
that that would be allowed so
how's the committee feel about something
like that
good do you want to do you want to start
drafting something like that or would
you like me to look into it
that sounds good okay representative
I'm just wondering about the
the
[Music]
actual effect of saying okay you can
have as much time as you want or you can
have an extension maybe one extension or
something like that if you write this
letter
um you know they could just have the
copy machine going you know at full bore
like printing out these letters and and
sending them out
how does that actually
help that end user get their get their
driveway permit
faster I don't I don't see how sending
requiring the department to send a
letter helps
anyone
well I I like to think the Department's
not going to just print letters and send
them out to every single person that
asks for a permit I think that the
intent is so that somebody within a
single family you know area or
residential area should have
there should be reasonable timelines
placed on these State agencies to issue
permits so I think you're I think you're
what ifing it I don't think that the
that dot would do something like that
but
representative Walsh no I agree and
never underestimate the value of a paper
trail if you've got repeated letters
from A Department that's the do nothing
um it goes a long ways for your file so
they I even allowing them to have the
letter I think could be advantageous
thank you Mr chairman I'll take you back
to
um 80 with department environmental
services subsurface they had a
regulations they had 30 days to review
an application they did on many many an
occasion wait till day 29 to send out
the letter and here's why I'm not going
to do it once we're able to catalog how
many times that was happening we then
came back in and their their present
processes now that they will they will
process almost every application within
two days so the paper trail that was
mentioned is is uh is a good process
I like it
two days two day permitting issue that
sounds good yeah
perfect
all right anything else on Department of
Transportation
okay representative Reed
last but not least can you please
present on your two bills I I sure can
now
um
so I'm going to just rather than step
through every step of both bills they're
they are largely identical the only
thing that is different is the expansion
of uh one unit by right to two so I'm
just going to work off of the 2260
Amendment which is the all-inclusive one
and then when we get to places of
difference I will
tell you that it's different
um so the first three Roman numerals
here are definitions we have cleaned up
the definitions
um so accessory dwelling unit is what we
think of as an accessory dwelling unit
it's located on a lot containing a
single family dwelling and it provides
independent living and then we go into
the definitions of attached and detached
representative yokella has already made
me aware of some grammatical changes
that should be made primarily the
definition should say attached unit or
attached accessory dwelling unit and
detached unit and also in in number
three detached there's con some
redundancy that needs to be simplified
but there's nothing substantive there
moving on so this is one of those places
where the two bills are different two
accessory dwelling units shall be
allowed without additional requirement
for lot size except as described in the
section setbacks aesthetic requirements
design review requirements so that is
obviously not in
the um the the one that excludes that
expansion to two
I will say that this part that is in the
same area is is on this bill the 2260
but it's further down so I will just
wait till I get there
um and then it basically is saying the
same thing as that first paragraph on
line 17 is saying I mean municipality
that adopts a zoning ordinance will
allow to buy right and then the
paragraph two on line 30 is that if no
zoning ordinance contains Provisions
um then two units will be allowed by
right so that's also not in the other
version
we had discussed as a committee and
decided I believe collectively to just
strike the requirement for a door
between the accessory dwelling unit and
the primary structure uh and I had
spoken with others and just nobody had a
reason whether it was Town planners or
anybody else why that was required to
begin with and since we have detached
units or units that are considered
attached but in pre-existing detached
structures it just didn't make sense to
to have it so it's completely struck
um the following paragraph So This is
where this is on page one of the other
version but the point is is that and
this was from mercatus this was a
um an ask for mercatus so uh
the existing language is that uh
Municipal regulation apple is single
family drilling shall apply to the
combination of the principal drawing
unit and an Adu but not limited to lot
coverage standards or standards for
maximum occupancy per bedroom consistent
with policy adopted by U.S Department of
Housing or Urban Development then the
addition is what was requested provided
that such Municipal regulations shall
not be more restrictive for adus than
for the principal dwelling unit so a
town can't kind of up that requirement
if that requirement was not on the
original
structure I mean as a spelling may
require additional parking to accommend
this is what we discussed in in
committee uh additional parking to
accommodate in Adu and here we are
specifying but it shall not be more than
one spot per bedroom and I did confirm
that a studio apartment is considered
one bedroom
so the paragraph Roman numeral four is
already in law that just says that a
town can deny it on the basis of an
inadequate
septic plan
um in water also paragraph five the
municipality may require owner occupancy
of one of the units also already in law
but can't say which unit so an owner
could for example move into their own
Adu and then rent out the primary
structure
uh paragraph six a municipality May
establish standards for adus for the
purpose of maintaining aesthetic
Community with principal dwelling in his
single family dwelling this is already
in law I would not have come up with
that the part that we changed here is uh
changing the fact that towns can
restrict it down to 750 square feet
meaning the maximum size for an Adu
would top out at 750 if the town so
chose changing that to a thousand square
feet for one of the units Allowed by
right in 850 for any other unit
and then we had talked about some and
this is going way back to one of the
presentations but the idea of not having
an Adu bigger than the primary dwelling
unit and uh in order to address that we
say if the primary structure is a
thousand square feet or less the
municipality May restrict any of the
accessory dwelling units 800 square feet
because this references the potential
for more than one Adu that's allowed by
right
um the language has changed in the other
version to reflect that there's no
second one that's allowed by right
but the whole point of that change in
square footage was to really bring these
adus more into the normal market for
housing because at 750 square feet we're
really being exclusionary to like a lot
of small families you're really only
talking about one occupant usually
uh paragraph seven a municipality may
not require a familiar relationship
between the occupants of the Adu which
is already in law also in law is in law
is paragraph eight may not the mean
spelling may not limit an Adu to only
one bedroom paragraph nine an accessory
joining unit may be deemed a unit of
Workforce housing for purposes of
satisfying the municipality's obligation
so we're saying that this helps towns
reach their Workforce housing
requirements also and this is specific
to this version which includes the
second Adu that a municipality may
require that if a property has two or
more accessory dwelling units one of
them shall meet the criteria
meaning that they still have the ability
to restrict that second unit provided
by saying that the person developing
that unit has to rent that out at
Workforce housing levels so we lose that
kind of carrot in in really that benefit
to the entire housing market if we don't
have the second Adu
um
paragraph 10 a municipality shall allow
adus to be converted from existing
structures including but not into two
garages regardless of whether such such
structure violates current dimensional
requirements for setbacks or lot
coverage this was a clarification again
from mercatus
and then finally this is the whole
reason we had to Define attach and
detach so under detach accessory
dwelling units this was the current uh
language that we are changing a
municipality is required to permit
detach accessory dwelling units for at
least one unit Allowed by right under
this chapter but may require any other
units to be attached so again with the
changes made here
a talent at most if a town exercises its
right to limit according to what we've
set forth here at most a person would be
able to have one attached Adu which you
would not visually recognize as an Adu
most likely and then one detached at a
maximum so you wouldn't see like
multiple extra structures you might see
a barn and then maybe one extra
structure
so a municipality and finally the other
ability we've given municipalities to
restrict adus is it may require a
property to have a minimum lot size of
up to one half acre in order to have
more than one Adu so
um that doesn't impact the current 180
ueu have by right but if we were to
expand that to two the town could still
say but your lot is under a half acre
and I think based on all of the the
water stuff that was brought up earlier
that that seems to be reasonable and I'm
happy to take questions I see a hand
um thank you representative Reed
representative
thank you
um so they're in that last paragraph
there is some differences between the
two
um because there's no
um second
um unit allowed I guess and in the
um specifically on the the other
Amendment uh not doing the second it
does not allow the municipality to
require uh minimum lot size of up to
half an uh
acre
um I'm just
uh I'm one
I am not in favor of that thing I'm
wondering if you were doing this
language on 19 and 20 because like as a
as something to try and get the the
towns to be
in support of because it's right now you
can have uh accessory dwelling unit
whether or not you have a half acre or
not
um and so this
you are in 8 19 and 20 or 19 and 20 it
just says a municipality may require
property to have a minimum lot size of
up to half an acre to have more than oh
more than one okay more than one well so
just so I I'm on record so yeah we're
not I I very very explicitly told OLS
repeatedly over this bill and all of the
Amendments I do not want to touch our
one Adu buy right at all whatsoever that
is not touched in any segment or any
version of any bill
um what this is doing and you're right
that this was a bit of a sweetener and a
compromise to say
yes I understand that some people are
worried about super dense neighborhoods
popping up and this is to say look a
half acre is pretty reasonable to have
that you know one structure that's the
primary structure with an attached Adu
that you can't even really visually
delineate is an Adu necessarily and then
maybe one extra outbuilding
um a half acre is reasonable for that
and it not overly dense it still looks
very very rural so everything in this
everything about this is about gentle
density so no it's uh this you're right
that this was a kind of a compromise
that I put in but it does not impact the
one Adu we have by right okay thank you
and um representative Reed I
we don't know a lot about New Hampshire
adus because we don't have a database or
any research on it I think that's
something that um Noha just brought up
um when he presented but I guess
um
I don't
I don't even see with this bill that
there would be just a bunch of ads
popping up everywhere in like single
family neighborhoods I think that the
way that you I I really think on page 3
19 and 20 I think that helps address if
you're going to have more than one it's
going to be on a minimum acre lot and I
think that
is a very good sweetener compromise in
this amendment and I didn't I don't
remember seeing it on previous versions
uh this was in the original uh 423
um however I completely agree with you
Mr chair that part of the gentle density
of this isn't just the visual impact
that it's not you know you're spreading
out the increased units we need for our
Market rather than having several large
complexes go up that total 60 000 units
you'll have this kind of victory garden
decentralized approach to increased uh
increased units on the market but in
addition to that as you pointed out it's
not like everyone who
um is able to have an Adu is going to
build the next day this is going to be
slowly over time and it's something that
directly helps homeowners afford their
mortgage whether to buy a home because
as a a
aspiring home buyer myself I know that
the ability to build an Adu is going to
help me defray the cost of the mortgage
but also especially as people retire and
now they're faced with property taxes
that are continuing to go up having an
Adu helps them stay in their home and
not have to sell and downsize so
um so yeah it's not going to happen
overnight but it's something that helps
over the long term slowly
okay
um where's the rest of the committee on
this any feedback for representative
Reed representative Damon
I'm fully in support of the 2adu version
for all the reasons stated
um and I would further note I went to a
workshop last spring
on putting adus that was co-hosted
across New Hampshire Vermont border
and one of the realities that was
presented by several different folks
adus are not inexpensive to build
so we're not going to have an onslaught
of them in existing homes
there's really Nationwide data about
that
um and I could find a link and send to
the committee
but I think this is a small part of our
solution and it's creative
it's good for young people as well as
old people old people get to stay in
their homes more affordably and pay
those taxes or if they still have a
mortgage which is a surprising number of
seniors do still have mortgages
and for younger folks it makes them more
able to become homeowners so I fully
supported them
representative lines up I fully support
it sounds like a really great plan
number two okay yep there's two versions
of this amendment so are you saying you
support both versions
yes representative Damon representative
thank you Mr chairman I support it all
so I think there's a such a shortage of
rentals out there
um I know a lot of people who have had
to
move out of town to go live with their
parents because they can't afford the
rents in Manchester but um the rental
market is very bad in Manchester people
are going up like crazy on the rent
young people can't afford it this gives
an opportunity for a family to
Turn part of their property into an Adu
and bring their children home some
people don't want to move back in with
their parents because they have a
significant other or whatever and they
just don't want to bring that person
home but with an Adu it makes it a lot
more comfortable for people to even
bring the family together in many cases
I could name a half a dozen people that
have had to move out of town because
they have to go back with their parents
and just this would really take that
part of the pressure off a lot of young
people young people can't afford to buy
interest rates are up uh we do have that
new mortgage with one percent down but
now you're you're financing all money so
I don't know you know it's a catch-22
there
I'm in support of this I think it might
be a short fix uh for now but um I think
it'll be beneficial to everyone
thank you
okay
represent Walsh
I knew you were coming I'm working
around the table yeah
um I appreciate all the work that's gone
into this and and the creativity I still
cannot support it I I look at
the accessory dwelling units that are in
current statute and understand and have
no opposition to them uh accessory
dwelling unit that's why the door was in
between the two units for family for for
uh for for parents in-laws Etc this bill
basically takes your single family
neighborhoods or allows actually no it
by right anybody that lives in a single
family neighborhood which people like
them that's why they shop there and buy
their
uh they're invested in their
neighborhoods they know everybody and it
turns it into a potential apartment
type of development and I just I don't
see the the commingling and I look at
something like this and if a
municipality wanted to adopt something
like this and the people in their Town
said yeah that's a great idea let's do
it by all means but for us as a state to
look at every city and town in this
state as a government and say this is
what you need to do or need to allow I
just think it goes too far for me so
I'll leave it at that yeah and I'm just
so the May
don't we have to enable municipality or
to adopt these regulations first before
they're allowed to do it themselves
so that's kind of I stand correct
language in here is is that but um I'm
gonna let representative McConkey jump
in first and then go back around the
table
thank you um I will um
I will support this I
um we have a tremendous need for housing
um I think allowing people to age in
place is hugely important I can name you
Lake after Lake after Lake in my region
that as the tax burden goes higher and
higher the families and mom and dad who
have been there since they swam and the
thing as a kid have to move out so I I
was fully supportive Adu I'll go to two
I think if you had done this instead of
trying to get five we would already have
this right now so I will wholeheartedly
support this
representative Reed
thank you
um
I think I think the representative might
be referring to the fourplex bill which
was not mine but mine was always two but
that's fine uh
uh but that's fine
um I do appreciate the comments I I will
just add that
um the expansion from one by right which
I I'll further record that was a bill
that was put in by Republicans
um and of course I support but the
expansion from one by right to to two by
right um what that really allows is to
have that family member that you were
talking about and the current law does
not restrict to family members it's very
clear that it cannot be restricted to
family members and can they already can
and are rented and rooms in homes in
single-family homes just the rooms are
also rented so that's none of that is
being impacted that's already in place
that's already happening but what this
does allow is for someone to not only
bring that family member in but also
help defray their own mortgage costs as
well as adding a unit to not only the
market but specifically a Workforce
housing level unit to the market which
is super important to bring down costs
because sixty thousand units adding 60
000 units to the market won't do
anything if those units are not
affordable
so
um and again as was already pointed out
by other Representatives it's it is not
easy to build a new Adu if you're
building a new structure and it's not
like a garage or a barn and even then
it's not easy or cheap so it's not like
an entire neighborhood all of a sudden
every single house is going to have an
extra Adu
um and certainly the visual impact even
if that happened eventually wouldn't it
would still look very rural but it's not
like you're going to change the nature
of an entire neighborhood and I guess
I'll leave it at that and I appreciate
the time Mr chair I think so I grew up
in Concord and uh I grew up in a single
family neighborhood and I think our
Acres were like a quarter of a lot but
it still had kind of the single family
neighborhood Vibe so I mean a half acre
is a lot of space it's a in my opinion
it's a lot of space and and it's not
usually the typical size of a a lot in a
single family neighborhood
and I'll just add to that Mr chair very
briefly that what this is really going
to impact is not the municipal lots that
are an eighth of an acre obviously for
that very reason but as we've talked
about the very kind of
overburdensome lot minimum requirements
in so many uh towns five acres 10 acres
20 acres and what this allows is
actually a little bit more housing on
those massive pieces of property
represent Walsh and I I'm not welcoming
a debate on this again uh I just want to
make a comment I my my lot is 0.6 Acres
it may look like a lot of space until
you put a thousand square foot house in
the middle of it then it's no longer a
big space that is not a large piece of
property so I guess it's all a matter of
perspective uh on this type of
discussion and I just think this goes
too far from what we already have that's
all yep and that's okay I think I I do
want to thank representative Reed for
going to the drawing board three or four
or five times and listening to the views
of the committee
um it's definitely made me more
comfortable I'm happy to co-sponsor
whichever one you decide to introduce
God representative
um I guess
I didn't hear
um any thoughts from representative
Walsh about one versus another if one
would be able to be supported versus
another because it seems like if he
opposed to both of them there's no
reason to go with the non-2-1 right if
he's if he's supportive of the non-2-1
that fixes some other things then maybe
there might be incentive for a
representative Reed to choose that one
as or if she you know when she's
considering filing legislation that
would be important information I think I
didn't hear that from him so I I would
be interested
representative Reed with the blessing of
the committee and to simplify our work
in the spring
um I think it might be wise to just put
in the one version and then have the uh
Amendment available should the committee
eventually decide to get rid of the two
and go with all of the other pieces but
at least you will have that language
available to amend the bill but I can
just put in the whole kit and caboodle
in that way we're dealing with one bill
instead of two bills
yes and we haven't heard from the public
on this
specific legislation so that's a good
good idea
um representative wall should you want
to jump in on that yeah thank you well
first of all I did I just got the uh PDF
copies of these this morning at 4 30 I
did not have a chance and I haven't read
the second one which is two six two two
six one-h
um skimming it over real quick
it does not look to be as much and again
like I said before I'm not opposed to
making changes or amendments that remove
a municipality's ability to make them
impossible like the parking restrictions
But to answer your question in public I
have not reviewed the second one yet
I will say that when I was going through
the bill I I pointed out the differences
in um basically it's identical except
for every place that it referenced a
second Adu buy right that that part has
been removed and the effect of that is
that we're also removing the ability for
towns to enforce Workforce housing level
rents on that second unit because we no
longer have that second unit by right
representative McConkey I would um I got
a little lost in that conversation the
um the amendment that I will
wholeheartedly support is
22608 I think if we have two too much
out there it becomes hard to sort
through
and I believe that is the amendment
representative that handled all of your
changes that you wanted that is correct
that's the one that I was going through
line by line yeah that's that's the one
I would support okay so that's the one
that takes a bigger bite of the Apple
yep one big bite
um representative Wallace and
representative thank you the other thing
that needs to be considered is
it's not going to be all over the place
as previously stated because uh you know
a 750 to a thousand square foot Adu is
going to cost somewhere is you know 75
to 150 000 to construct and there's also
going to be the tax revenue to the
municipalities uh they're from so it's
not going to be the uh immediate cure
that people think it's going to be
there's going to be a cost of doing
business with this
um so keep that in mind folks I will
support this
I just wanted to also make sure we noted
that this is a way to keep
young people post high school and post
College in New Hampshire and we are
losing
our young population because they can't
afford to live here and this would make
it substantially more possible
foreign
with you just drafting that and sending
that to the committee
um I guess my ask for the committee is
do we feel like we need to meet one more
time before drafting to go over
um representative Wallace's language
I'm gonna come back with another bite at
the impact fees and then represent
McConkey has some language and then
maybe something coming from
representative Walsh
does the committee feel like we need to
meet one more time
yes
representative thank you Mr chair
um
I that at the last
at the last uh meeting I had proposed
some language as far as amending
um what requirements there would be for
um
designation of housing champion
now that I kind of have a direction for
those
um lot
um
size requirements I could do an
amendment
um that that incorporated those
um I'm thinking of something along the
lines of like
um no more than double
um that the suggestions from De the Des
as far as the lot line uh lot
requirements and
um and also if they go lower than double
than they're giving you know that's
considered also
um as as benefit for being being
designated a housing champion and
um I was also trying to get some
information about how Seattle was doing
their
um
their pre-approval or kind of like
approval of
um designs over
uh
over that entire area for their adus I
wanted it to be more holistic something
that incorporated you know could be used
for 3D printed houses or off-site built
houses or whatever
um
but
um what I found out is that
they didn't really pass a law they just
they just um like their committee
they're uh like city council or whatever
voted to accept those
um
those uh plans and then kind of granted
those plans some special designation and
so I haven't really found anywhere that
is doing that same type of thing but
um
I still kind of want to move forward
with that
um
and maybe
see if I could have like a committee
um that might accept and approve those
types of things maybe
um utilizing maybe I need to talk with
like the plan the regional planning
um
people as far as
maybe who would be the
how that might be structured or
something like that my suggestion is
that you reach out to the the housing
Champion program was one that was just
created yeah I recommend you reach out
it was on
office of professional
planning okay office of planning and
development and ask them they're they're
currently in the rulemaking process to
um
establish the rules on on
how a housing Champion is created like
what municipalities become happy
Champions
um so I would have a conversation with
them around what they're doing the
rulemaking process and if there needs to
be like
a rough outline put into the law about
it I think there's some Merit to it the
housing Champion's obviously an opt-in
program it's not a mandate on
municipalities
um so I would recommend first that you
reach out to them and see kind of what
their what the step is in their process
and then if it's something that
they can get done through the rulemaking
process maybe we can as a committee help
guide them
on what our recommendations are for
rules
um or we can go straight into
legislation but I don't know if that's
necessarily needed
any thoughts about the um the like
Statewide approval of plans of the
direction that that would be good to go
for that
for what I was talking about you know
for the last I don't know three minutes
where I was saying that that Seattle
approved some Adu plans Citywide I I
would like to see New Hampshire have a
similar plan Statewide that may work for
any type of plan whether that be a 3D
printed plan or whatever if you have
this plan you could go to a board at
that the state designates and that if
that plan was approved at that board you
wouldn't have to go
to the local every single time you want
to print this 3D printed house that plan
would already be approved and you would
only be going to local municipalities
for the
the specific
um uh
site work that needs to be done before
they can build that house right with the
foundation and the drainage and stuff
like that but the actual building
structure would already be approved and
and at at uh a state level so that's
kind of my idea and I am not exactly
sure of the blueprint for that since
Seattle didn't really do that they just
said hey we're going to accept some
plans and gr and do that so maybe
um either the housing people or or the
regional planning people might have an
idea about how to move forward with kind
of a regional adoption of specific plans
that are submitted by by people for that
purpose yeah I think a lot of us are in
agreement on that I think maybe Ben
would be a good person to at least talk
to about that verse but would it not
make sense to have the uh
yeah would it not make sense to have the
building code associate enforcement
Association where they have all the
disciplines needed the engineers the
electricians the plumbers
um they could you know they understand
all the uh you know the the engineering
detail and they could say yes this is a
viable idea and we bless this for for
Statewide use
they already have the authority to
handle disputes in those areas so that
might be a smart resource
representative boss and representative
I shouldn't do this so I'm just inviting
myself for a Marblehead movement moment
um
I guess I just don't understand this
pre-approved house or model
because even land use boards planning
zoning they deal with actual the
subdivisions the place you put the house
they're not even required in most cases
to even see where the house is going to
go short of the fact that you've got a
buildable spot outside of your radius
for both well and septic so I and even
if you had models I guess that were by
approved and again I still don't
understand this there's no re I haven't
seen requirements for what you want to
build on a house they would still
probably need to be inspected by
somebody regardless of whether or not it
was an approved plan so I just don't
understand I'm missing something on this
whole conversation
representative Rudy thank you Mr
chairman I think
for many years I've been a modular home
dealer we have those plans all approved
I've bought homes from Canada from
Pennsylvania from other places these
homes are all approved they've got a
third party inspector that comes in and
inspects the wiring the plumbing
everything so if a plan is approved by a
third party they're acceptable and I
believe every city and town in the state
So the plan itself is the house itself
is approved so I'm not sure what you
want to add on to that
okay representative yokella and then
I'll go over a second so what you're
talking about is a federal plan of
approval they were approved at a federal
level I'm saying not things that are not
HUD approved plans like not federally
approved it would be state approved it
would have a different level of approval
right so you could be HUD compliant or
you could be just New Hampshire
compliant right no what
if I'm going to build a house I'm going
to build a house in Rochester another
one over and Dover and another one in
Concord every town has certain maybe
difference of approval levels or
whatever that they need
this third party researches everything
that your town requires
and they approve it
and it's built to the approval it's
built to the requirements of every
different city in town
so they won't even build it unless it
meets all the requirements and it's
inspected
with all those requirements in place
representative Reed
and I think I'm maybe asking for
clarification from representative
viokala but is not the point then to say
because some of the municipalities have
been overly restrictive on anything
that's like non-conventional for example
3D printed homes Quonset homes which
have really become quite the thing and
there's like five million dollar Quonset
Mansions now whereas quonsets used to be
considered Huts so quonsets are these
um domed arched metal structures they're
what are built what's that World War II
when you think of World War II Barracks
that's the Army created quonsets to go
up very quickly be very sturdy be very
cheap and very efficient and they are so
good that they come with a 50-year
weather guarantee which is something you
do not get with the stick build and they
are the structure that is built in
Antarctica to house the scientists so
these are very high quality structures
and yet towns will look look at them
because they're different I will say the
Whittemore Center one part of the
Whittemore Center that many of us met in
when we went to UNH during covid that is
a Kwanzaa the Elks Lodge in Dover is the
Kwanzaa so they're very very common and
yet towns will Zone them out because
they're non-conventional and so getting
back to the point uh representative
yokella isn't the point then to say to
have a Statewide approval mechanism for
these structures by which the state has
said this structure is fine and
therefore the municipalities can't say
no to that particular they can do all
the site stuff and everything and the
inspections to make sure it meets what
it claims to me but then they can't say
no just because something is
non-traditional
I wasn't I my goal was not to be so
limiting to only
Innovative techniques but
yes if something is let's say
unconventional and the person is
building you know 10 of these homes and
they don't want to have to
go and explain the science of why this
works 10 different times they just want
to do it one time to a governing body
that oversees and can understand and
doesn't have maybe that bias then they
you know whether that be you know lack
of knowledge about 3D printed or or the
the type of structure that is being
discussed
um that it would be allowed
yes I've seen them before
um that they
that they would be allowed and without
jumping through additional hurdles of
you know oh we want the you know the we
don't we want to expose brick
in our you know our local regulations
doesn't allow us exposed you know cement
to be the the you know whatever the
facade of the building or whatever that
kind of stuff would not be allowed to be
um you know
as as the representative says like oh
it's going to be designed every single
time it's going to be changed
um to meet those type of of uh
restrictions in each different
municipality if you have a structure
that makes sense
um then you can just produce that
structure okay so with the goal of
wrapping up I'm going to call and
represent Walsh
yeah now I understand what the goal is
and that's to have these atypical
mass-produced houses that by right in
the state of New Hampshire you can put
them anywhere you want so I can't wait
to see if the the burnt out a lot in the
middle of Hooksett Village uh with the
the ornate victorians on both sides and
uh let's go plump one of these things in
there that's going to go over well now I
I understand now thank you
okay all right
thank you representative Walsh for being
on this committee I appreciate it
um is there any other business or can we
break um I looking good
I think I think the assignments I'm
gonna have represented what I I want to
meet next week how does everybody feel
about that all right okay
yeah do it all right so we're gonna meet
next Tuesday I'm gonna expect some
language from representative
there's something going on Tuesday isn't
it
that's the day after Labor Day we're
gonna
does less does next Wednesday work for
the committee
okay that's fine but you can send me
some stuff if you have it I'll have my
hookup done and I'll be here okay so
let's plan on next Wednesday potentially
I'm gone all day I'm recording
the day after Labor Day I'm in court
Wednesday and Thursday next week it's
Tuesday afternoon
mark
okay so we're gonna do next Tuesday at
10 A.M okay
Tuesday Tuesday
the 5th thank you very much
have a good one